claire county health officials they're
trying to make it a bit easier for
people to get tested in a statewide
mitigation meeting the emergency manager
said
they will focus on the hardest hit of
areas joe moeller spoke to him today
to explain the increased efforts to
lower the numbers joe
well as cases go up around the state
health officials say they need to take
some action and
and make up a plan and so now they do
have one now take a look at this map it
shows the uh the hardest hit areas here
it's locally here in southern nevada
you can see the zip codes in red those
are the hardest hit areas you can see
the central valley and the east side
have
a lot more red compared to the rest now
during the copa 19 mitigation and
management meeting we learned strike
forces will set up
testing efforts in the top eight to ten
zip codes that are
the worst now these sites aren't exactly
new but soon they will do a lot more of
them i stopped by a testing site that
was held at cheyenne high school in
north las vegas earlier
clark county emergency manager billy
samuel says they want to create more
times at the sites and increase
hours over the next several weeks a
woman getting tested despite not showing
symptoms is happy to hear
more testing will be available in her
area they got a lot of testing places so
there's no excuse it's good because
a lot of people are getting it and dying
so it's more or less i feel like be safe
than sorry
clark county has opened texas station as
a new site as well it was open before
this makes it easier for people in the
northern part of the valley as far as
strikeforce pop-up sites here is a list
of the next
few sites the next pop-up location will
be on tuesday the 17th at doolittle
community center
that will be open from 8 a.m until 12
p.m now right now those testing sites
the mobile ones are set up through
the beginning of next month they do plan
to have a lot more they might make
changes to the hours so they can
double the amount of tests that they do
conduct reporting live joe muller 8 news
now